it's officially January 1st 2024 and I
got a direct message for you some of you
going to love this you're going to
respond to it some of you're going to
hate this message but either way I only
know one way I only know how to lead
amongst leaders because that's been my
goal in life since I was 28 years old
let me give it to you in the last 24
months in many other people in my life
that I'm leading they've become very
wealthy some of them have become
decamillionaires some of them have
become millionaires they're driving nice
cars they have beautiful homes have
money in the bank they got nice clothes
nice food all this stuff that's just
like $6 $7,000 clothes and the stuff
that they're doing suits but I found a
leak I don't think this is talked about
enough and I want to kind of give it to
you so 2023 in America Ukraine war
Israel Palestine Gaza Hamas War lots of
people dying both places one hundreds of
thousands of people dying the other one
heartbreaking videos we watching why is
this happening well because typically if
there's not a leader in the Free World
that the enemy and bullies and tyrants
fear respect then they take advantage of
it in 2023 nobody fears respects or
loves America they just don't love is
typically the last one for a great
leader where people love him fine that's
a bonus maybe Reagan was loved but you
need fear and respect in America no one
fears our leader no one respects our
leader you may say that's the president
but it's not a level of fear right so
that's in the leadership game you need
to be able to impose that and when there
is a fear of not screwing up the
temperatures all goes down right how
about in life with you in 2024 Who Do
You Love simple question I'm asking you
Who Do You Love just think about that
you may have said I love my mom cool who
else do you love I love my kids
fantastic who else do you love I love my
brother I love my sister great who else
do you love I love God okay cool what
else I love my career great out of all
the people you mention of the people you
love do you admire your kids no I don't
they're my kids these 16 years old I I I
love them it's kind of a weird question
Fair my daughter's 6 years old I can't
admire her but I love her it's I love
her okay cool all right um You Who do
you admire who do I admire uh I admire
my mother okay cool I I admire you know
XYZ no problem but some of you may have
said I love my mother but I don't if I
admire my mother it's kind of weird I
just love my mother all right yeah I
love my dad but I don't know if I admire
him he kind of ran off and you know he
he made a lot of decisions that I just
don't respect but you know I I admire
him okay cool so now watch this do you
have anybody in your life that you love
that you used to admire 12 years ago but
you don't admire them today yeah where
are you going with that there are
certain people in life that want the
admiration for something they did 18
years ago 16 years ago 3 years ago but
if you want the level of admiration
today you got to earn to be admired
today so let me paint a picture for you
imagine a husband and wife are sleeping
in bed okay wife's back to husband's
back okay husband is asking himself the
question does my wife love me I think so
does my my wife admire and respect me
today I don't know so imagine then the
wife is on this side oh man I freaking
love my husband but dude whatever
happened to the guy that was driving
working hungry taking a family I miss
that guy what she's saying is I admired
you 3 years ago I don't admire you today
oh my gosh can you imagine that so so
for me as a man who has been blessed at
levels I never thought I'm going to be
blessed at this levels with God's giving
me this incredible life and I'm by the
way I'm not telling you everything's
good today we've had to put a lot of
fires but it's still been a great day
right it's right before Christmas and
we're shooting this video but I can't
believe my life I can't believe the
blessings he's given me I can't believe
what's going on but can you imagine if I
said well let me tell you what I did 6
years ago and I want admiration today of
the work I did yesterday of six years
ago that's not how it works what if
imagine my kids I got four of them right
and I tell my kids do you know your
daddy used to work very hard at 32 years
old but I'm not sitting around like a
schlep and they're like well Dad I don't
know you may used to work I've never
seen seen you work before I've never
seen you work hard before Dad maybe it's
a myth maybe my dad never worked hard no
I want to be admired for the work I'm
doing today I think sometimes with the
era we're living in today we want love
so much which is needed we want respect
so much but at what level you want
today's level of respect or maybe stuff
you did before you we respect each other
right and then we want to be admired but
what what kind of a level of admiration
you want you want to be like Al Bundy
back in high school you remember when I
threw a four touchdowns and yeah bro
that was like 22 years ago or that was 3
years ago or that was 18 months ago
you're not admired today for today's
work so Pat that's not fair how could
you say something like that and you know
my wife and my husband I love my wife
listen I'm married I've been married now
for 14 and 1/2 years we take marriage
one year at a time I got to tell you I
love my wife and I admire her for what
she does today and my wife's the richest
she's ever been but I admire for the
work she does today on how she looks
over for the kids what she does with
work her office is right next to mine
we're still working together I admire
that she doesn't have to do that but I
love it and I admire it I what you what
kind of pressure you put in me as a wife
you all all understand what I'm doing
look you pick and choose what level of
admiration you want I told you don't
watch this video if you don't want to be
challenged this isn't for everybody but
all I'm saying to you today the world is
looking for leaders that want to be
admired for the work they're doing today
not a week ago not 2023 not 2022 and not
how much money you got in the bank today
because the work you did five years ago
or 3 years ago the market wants to give
you respect today that you want and
deserve based on what you're doing today
January 1 2024 so you get to pick and
choose guess what 2024 here's what I
want in 2024 really okay what are you
willing to do to earn the level of
admiration that you want today love you
don't have to do a lot to earn Leed a
love your family loves you your mom dad
love you whoever in your family is your
kids love you kids are going to love
kids will forgive their parents to
because they want to have a great
relation with the father your father can
go and come back you're still going to
love you like I can't stand the fact you
weren't there when I needed you from 14
to 18 years old but I love my dad I love
you know it's love is a we want to love
the people we love right but admiration
is a lot of work man it's a lot of work
I don't know if you wanted a heavy
message like this or not you you can go
pick and choose and watch another cat
video after this go watch maybe some of
these funny videos If you really into go
watch the baby shark video I mean you
know if you want to get into the mood
but at 28 years old I said I want to be
a leader amongst leaders which means
everybody around me I'm going to
constantly challenge everybody to do
that because whatever message I'm giving
you trust me the first person I'm giving
that message to is this guy here that's
where the pressure comes from okay and I
don't know how much longer you going to
live I don't know how much longer I'm
going to live but the feeling of using
the blessings and the gifts God's given
you the friendships the relationship the
amount of things we can be grateful for
to say man I'm the luckiest man alive
the luckiest woman alive you know what I
want to go out there and make everybody
around me proud and I want to earn the
level of admiration in a humble way in a
non arrogant conceited way I want to
stay curious I want to stay hungry I
want to stay willing to work improve all
of that stuff because aside from that
what am I going to be known for stuff I
did in the past I don't want to be known
as that person so if you're a true
bainer Community this message is going
to resonate with you and it's just going
to go Wom and you're going to receive it
if we're new to the value tment
Community we may or may not be for you
you may be like freaking this is amazing
this is exactly what I want awesome
great you know it's funny we're talking
about the conferences we host the
conference once year called the wall
conference and that's the big Super Bowl
the one that we do we're going to have
nearly 10,000 people this year at Palm
Beach when our crew gets together the
Vault of the itainment crew when they're
together last one we did we had Tom
Brady at this event everybody that talks
to each other like dude I kind of feel
like I'm talking to myself I kind of
feel like I'm talking to my own self all
I'm saying to you is you know I if this
message resonates well then put a plan
together and ask yourself what am I
going to do this year to get the level
of admiration I want for my wife my
husband my kids my parents my brother my
siblings my co-workers my community my
state all of that and then go execute if
you got value of this video give it a
thumbs up subscribe to the channel and
if you want to watch a video of somebody
that you can fully admire by the time
you're done with this interview
especially on January 1st click here to
watch my favorite interview I've ever
done in my life and that's with the late
Kobe Bryant trust me he will make you
realize the value and the importance of
being admired today not 20 or 30 years
ago take care everybody bye-bye bye-bye
bye-bye